you're right now you're doing like baby
giraffe walking you want to be very
confident so keep your core tight you
want to like glide across the room yes
[Music]
hi everyone and welcome to another
episode of what does it mean today we
have a submission from aria and he has a
question about guys and high heels let's
hear what he had to say I saw a couple
of guys on the street the other day walk
it into my heels and you know I mean
nothing against that I just I'm not
really used to seeing that is that cool
in order to answer your question or I
invited yet again a resident gait expert
dr. Ryan Graham oh I mean again not a
doctor so we have a submission from aria
I do understand his curiosity when it
comes to men in heels I give that a
question a lot I myself love with you
what are these payments no actually it's
called privet in you think about high
heels that's so surprising is that they
were actually worn by men long before
women we don't know the origins of high
heels we do know that before the 17th
century they were used by Eastern
horseback riders so they could stand up
in the stirrups more easily so while the
Eastern countries were using high heels
they would meet with other Western
civilization's and wear the high heels
and that's when they made the jump from
Eastern countries to more European in
the Western civilization's in the early
17th century a new fashion trend arose
in the upper class where women began
adopting men's style in their clothing
the new masculine wardrobe included
heels how do we get to where we are now
men straight away from strapping of
things towards the 1740s
the fashion was associated with
femininity and therefore a lot of men
stopped wearing things that were
associated with that such as heels the
french revolution comes around at the
end of the 18th century and things that
were seen as frivolous and upper-class
they were highly criticized and so women
stopped wearing high heels as well there
was a time when everyone was wearing
flats or kitten heels even worse it was
truly a dark time for passion in high
I don't think I would have survived but
luckily high heels made a huge comeback
in the mid 19th century and when we
started wearing high heels again so at
that point it seems like high heels are
so far removed from in fashion they just
stop wearing them you know what I think
the best thing we can do is just go to a
store and get you some heels okay so
we're gonna get you your first pair heel
so fun oh she's a perfect fit is this
good try to stand up in there okay but
look how good your calf wings look at
that you need to put the other one on
come on so soft shuffle is a by
swiftlock ball to totally come come oh
look at her
so now we're gonna give some of the
street men at the office a little heel
makeover now we're in the lobby of the
office and we're looking for our first
subject wait hey
you're straight guy allegedly have you
ever considered have you ever considered
wearing heels maybe like as a child like
you throw them on just to be like yeah
look at this but nothing I never did
that Wow Patrick there's a lot that we
needs on back here I think yeah I mean
and I just try to get back up real quick
did you see that as you noticed we do
have a gay expert right here he's gonna
queer either out of you okay but just
like your feet what size shoe do you
wear
I am a size 9 better divide the seven it
looks like you're gonna need the size 11
shoe
what hurts your masculinity no that's
fine
don't worry about your blood circulation
you only have them on for a few minutes
10 seconds it's just a lot of like
untangling [ __ ] you know I mean what's
that about that's the thing is supposed
to give you a lot of confidence you want
to have your shoulders back and make
sure you're always serving favor
what are you right now in these fields I
feel like a lawyer oh okay what cage
like I'm taking down Wall Street
Wow I think my feet looks pretty ugly in
these quite honestly don't blame the
heel baby behind us we have dr. Ryan
Graham actually teaching change gonna
take a long confident stride
you're a lawyer you were Ally McBeal
Ally Nabil you're gonna walk into that
courtroom gonna swing those doors open
you're gonna say hey fat cats
you're going down I know that's good
after a full five minutes of training
we're gonna see how zach is gonna handle
the heels oh look he's giving us
attitude yes you're a fashion model I
almost don't believe that he's not a
homosexual
can you run here right now you're doing
like baby giraffe walking you want to be
very confident so keep your core tight
you want to like light across the room
you wanna try again but honestly the
character was there I think we need the
purse first a purse we gotta figure that
you can get your purse you gotta figure
the purse
now this this feels like me it's not
aunt Fanning in order to top up his
performers we actually gave him props
and he has a witness
Wow I am cooking he's serving me Sex in
the City realness you're right I do or
you having these on really does make me
focus more on the way I carry myself how
do you think that went doctor I think
you're right really what I think a lot
of people learned a lot today we change
lives one heel at a time I'm sensing
that you're not taking us seriously
oh no we're trying to change your life
hey unsolved is on a new channel and now
you're burned subscribe here that was my
part
[Music]